[Music]
in only in America news I love America
ah damn it submitted by destiny loves JK
oh you're my destiny a man was accused
of pistol-whipping his friend over a
Bruno Mars song it sounds like which
state was there what do you think I mean
I want to say like Florida but sort of
salty yes Texas okay I'll give you a
hint it's not a state that we frequently
talk about Iowa North Dakota
Nevada Idaho Indiana my home state all
right I mean we do talk about Indiana
but not as often as like Florida no very
often it's very forgettable aren't you a
joy rudl all right so this takes place
in Indiana's a 71 year old man named
Roger okay
he are you talk with Mark argued with
his friend over hope that he's like no
it's really good yeah we whipped him
because he thinks he did they say we
what it was over like what it was over
they just said was over the song so this
is always saying that initially it was
Roger let me give you a face oh I want
to see what kind of pistol with him in
oh yeah that looks pretty good I'm
saying he's a big bur no offense dude I
thought it was a 71 year old was like an
old-ass revolver antique but this guy
looks like he's got a [ __ ] Glock yes
of anyway this dude Roger was talking to
the victim and like they were just
hanging out at his home and then they
started fighting over this song and who
performed it the billionaire it was I
want to be a billion that because
there's Brunel and what something Travis
or yeah one of them I forgot yeah but
then there's two guys on it so then they
were both right that's what happened I
was like no Bruno Mars disciple to Mars
yeah me but the victim kept saying like
no
it's it's sung by Bruno and then this
dude Roger was like no it's not and I
don't know what he was disagreeing for
it but then finally the victim showed
Roger proof that was Brewer was on that
song so cuz I don't know if it is his
song or if he was featured in it anyway
you did not like it Roger was not happy
she pulls out his revolver and then the
victim called him a chicken [ __ ] because
he pulled the gun didn't do it because
he didn't pull it yeah I see yeah so
then that's when Roger swung his gun at
him striking him in the face and it in
the arm and then the gun went off twice
oh my god while he was smacking uh yeah
yeah but no one was shot but they do
mention that the victim had like an
abrasion on his right forearm so that's
what happened can we see the victim no
piggys just a picture the guy was the
guy look like again Roger was charged
with battery with injury and criminal
recklessness with a deadly weapon
yeah so he was just mad he was wrong
yeah that or like just accept the fact
that he was wrong that it was Bruno Mars
yes one of those faces were he he just
looks like he's seen Indians died even
in the picture he doesn't look like he's
taking responsibility from I'm a Colts
fan yeah so is he then that's what
you're saying hmm I don't think he's a
Colts fan oh I think the victim was we
think he's he's giving a sigh died
during his freakin mug shot will you
look on his face I don't know it's not
my fault like all I see is a mullet and
there's no mullet there but I want to
see a molar so bad [ __ ] head or
mustache thing going on and just like it
looks like a guy that would have a
mullet he looks like a guy that doesn't
listen to boo no like how would he even
know like I want to know who he thought
it was me too
and I want to know what song they were
arguing I know this is Michael Jackson
this is the state of web journalism
today they don't even know what we want
to read about yeah
now my dude I want to read the most
important thing you left out that
happens all the time no oh it's like
they just need a story but they don't
have any details but they're like oh I
just got to get content out I think it's
because people do it's because people
don't know how to ask the right
questions because if I was a journalist
or if any one of us were we would ask
the right questions yeah like what song
were you guys arguing about oh really
which artists did you think yeah like
what did you who do you we should be
media journals yes
oh wait that's why we have just kidding
that's why our new correspondent that'll
be tight yeah vana in the field would be
tight that would be too cuz we ask the
questions that matter that people want
to know yeah and all these guys are
[ __ ] up cuz they're just like yeah
they just argued over Bruno's song but
the real news is he got pistol-whipped
we're like that's stupid that's part
some cares the funny part is what they
were arguing about I love this [ __ ] like
I kind of miss my stupid friends because
like I had a lot of stupid prideful
friends like in high school and all that
they would fight over like like which
rims are better and it would get heated
arguments and like yeah they will get
into like crazy fights because of like
stupid arguments about like yeah yeah I
think this rim is better than that rim
or this car don't even own a car yet ten
fights at my school or about somebody
who disrespected somebody else it was
always like well he disrespected me it's
like well he was disrespecting how did
he disrespect you he was looking at me
yeah it's [ __ ] dumb but then I miss
that because I miss laughing at but now
we have these people in a laugh at ya
but they're not my like people I know
you know like because they annoy you so
then you stop being friends with them
right but then you miss them again cuz
you're just like you don't have anything
to like talk about anymore it's just
boring taxes and stuff yeah yeah and
then if we did have this correspondence
and then we can ask him questions I
wonder what kind of questions that would
not pertain to the story you would want
to ask cuz I know you guys are freaking
creative you'd be like so what color
underwear
it's really just that we're very dumb
but the world is in a state of like
seriousness that I don't accept ya know
I'm always just like well let's see how
much dumb we can inject into this until
it explodes in a fun way that we all
enjoy
yeah like make a firework of dumb I like
that I just it's more fun yeah there's a
serious problem you can apply to any
news story where it's like a very
serious thing happened this altercation
occurred and like Joe said I want to
hear about what they were arguing about
yeah and like can you imagine in the
article it's like it's like he said [ __ ]
you and then she said will [ __ ] your mom
and then he said that's my mom you're
talking about like that why not it's so
[ __ ] stupid and true it's true yeah
so it's funny yeah if they really do
need content why can't they milk out the
entire conversation of the argument if
they were just saying they went to an
argue we're gonna give some good ass
ideas you know if this guy was a
correspondence and you went to the jail
cell to go to assets got all these
questions I'd only think you would get
the answers that you need or even ask
the questions that you want you like was
it this song who wants to be a
billionaire you'll be like he'll be like
yeah yeah I think it was that one cuz do
you like that song and it will start
arguing cuz he'll be like still sticking
to the awful lot of gun I'm like it is
Bruno Mars dude he's like on the other
side of the [ __ ] jail he's like fight
me well then he's also in prison so you
can just non-stop everyday send him
Bruno Mars get a mug a t-shirt a [ __ ]
thermos like all Bruno Mars stuff and he
and he needs that stuff like as
necessities in prison so he has to use
all his Bruno Mars stuff and everyone
just thinks is a big Bruno fan he
[ __ ] ruin his life in there and I
just go put your cassette tapes of Bruno
Mars they can't even play yeah that guy
looks like you don't think ascent for
sure that hell yeah you know you know
how they [ __ ] it up it's with all this
CD digital this thing I like you're in
that scratchy be like that I mean
quality of that a track or whatever like
those guys talk about
love that they want that warm analog
sound of the old-school recording I like
that [ __ ]
I do like us it does have character when
you hit play that like three set me like
oh yeah I love that man I don't know why
for some reason it's like old jazz or
like old music yeah it's like what I
love wording when like rappers rap over
that old jazz and they put a beat to it
and they let me sample it yeah I love
that
Kanye sometimes they go too hard in
there the only sample and I'm like damn
this is just wall-to-wall sampling boat
that's Kanye that's all he does a sample
yeah are you talking [ __ ] on Kanye bro
yeah I love a Suzy oh yeah no not
anymore you were weird it's [ __ ]
weird dude I can't release music video
though the bed one you know he's like a
giant block no that's I think that's
different like I think he was the
stylist or a creative director for porn
hubs like Awards I just remember seeing
that everywhere I was like well that's
funny as [ __ ] them how dare anyone hate
on that nothing funny as hell not hating
on us I liked it all right sometimes I
wonder if people are if they're doing
this as a big fun joke yeah
or if they're really serious and
pretentious about it's better if they're
we're they all like Kanye or like like
artists that take themselves really
seriously and then like they do
something that's really out of this
world and funny and it might be good art
but it's really funny to me yeah because
it looks like a Shia LeBouf everything
he does or tell if he's rolling or not I
think he's drawings good I really do but
are you serious for all that would not
really walk the lines that's why he's
got you by the balls my friend I don't
think it's serious at all
like he's doing a really good job at
playing seriously cannot ran down a
movie theater have everyone watch your
movie your movies non-stop and Crider 24
hours cry during it film yes it's
definitely a troll yes let's see he
doesn't enough were people simple people
simple simple minded people simple
something you like he is no longer
trolling but that's what he's trying
he's not trolling because this fool like
he was like you know child actors like
some [ __ ] happens to their brain so then
like I feel like he just kind of lost a
few marbles and that's what you don't
think he's just crazy narcissism I feel
like he's over it he thinks the industry
is a joke and so he's just [ __ ] troll
like that playing you too hard for
anyone not to see the trolling I'm sorry
it's too well pretty had an exhibit
where everyone could just sit there and
insult him all day yeah that was a
take-off on the that I'm a Brahma Vic
like performance piece yeah yeah no I
know but he but he was doing it to
apologize for like his little who's you
know narcissist Oh like you're right the
more serious the better it's better it's
like hey let's celebrate me honestly I
think Kanye's very serious subjects are
kelly is trapped in the closet a
masterpiece of I am awesome because when
people will have money like Kanye yeah
they can actually do dope [ __ ] I never
yes man and stuff they're like uh
everything I do is dope
but when people run out of money but
they still want to be like that like are
Kelly yeah it's even funnier when art
Kelly has so many Yes Men around them
that he's like hey what do you guys
think about doing the same beat for an
hour 45 I know like oh man you know what
it's so sick you should do it and he's
like yeah it is that sick and that's why
we have this masterpiece so I'm so glad
these guys have yes men around them
because I wouldn't get all this great
comedy gold
exactly
[Music]